[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte kollegen
die griechen schützen heute an der
grenze zur türkei das recht gegen die
gewalt die freiheit gegen die tyrannei
und europa gegen erdogan das kleine
christliche land am rande der eu wird
von einem skrupellosen islamisten
angegriffen unsere solidarität gehört
der griechischen nation leitet ganz
offen die migrantenströme an die
griechischen grenze damit die
mehrheitlich jungen männer übrigens
nicht aus syrien wir schon gehört haben
diese grenze stürmen er will uns ins
chaos stürzen das ist ein akt der
aggression der eine klare antwort
erfordert und die mittel dazu haben wir
in der hand aussetzung des abkommens
strafzölle stopp der rüstungs lieferung
oder auch stopp und stoppt der
visavergabe für reisen aus der türkei in
die eu
dagegen ist die unterwerfung haltung der
bundesregierung erbärmlich die einzige
sprache die dieser diktator versteht ist
die politik der stärke um das heißt
sanktion und nicht subventionen die
gestern im haushaltsausschuss noch mal
beschlossen nur ein blinder
konnte nicht sehen was pop schon während
der verhandlungen des deals mit der
türkei 2016 hat erdogan gesagt oder
gedroht wir können jederzeit die türen
nach griechenland öffnen und die
flüchtlinge in busse setzen was er jetzt
macht hat er damals schon angekündigt
die politische verantwortung für diese
verheerende lage trägt niemand anderes
als frau dr
angela merkel merkel hat den deutschen
grenzschutz geopfert um sich von der
presse als mutter teresa feiern zu
lassen
deshalb hat sie den grenzschutz in die
schmutzigen hände des despoten vom
bosporus gegeben und damit eben auch den
hebel in die hand europa zu erpressen
der eu tag leid dir ist merkels stil und
sein scheitern ist merkels scheitern
mit dem abkommen hat die kanzlerin das
schicksal europas und deutschlands auf
gedeih und verderb an die launen eines
islamisten gekettet erdogan hat
zehntausende oppositionelle eingekerkert
in syrien kooperiert er mit
dschihadisten in deutschland präsentiert
das ich gerne mit dem gruß der
muslimbrüder das ist also der partner
von dem alten meyer gesagt hat er sei
europäischer als viele europäer wie kann
eine regierung irland nur so andy
trinken
die ursache des desasters ist dass die
bundeskanzlei
die drittstaatenregelung des
grundgesetzes außer kraft gesetzt hat
diese besagt der zu fuß aus österreich 1
reist hat hier kein recht auf asyl also
kann er auch kein recht auf ein
asylverfahren haben also kann ja auch
schon gar nicht einreisen
helmut kohl schreibt in seinen
erinnerungen über die 93 durch
grundgesetzänderung eingeführte
drittstaatenregelung nur sie machte
europäische regelungen möglich nur sie
ermöglicht die volle teilnahme an
schengen und dublin nur die
drittstaatenregelung kann
schlepperbanden und anderen kriminellen
das wasser abgraben
was der kanzler der einheit damals
gesagt hat das gilt bis heute die
abweisung von asylbewerbern die aus
sicheren drittstaaten kommen ist der
schlüssel für die lösung der krise das
haben sie union spd und fdp damals mit
verfassungsändernde mehrheit beschlossen
und das war richtig denn sonst sieht der
deutsche sozialstaat migrantenströme aus
aller welt durch alle länder haben das
schaffen wir nicht und das wollen wir
auch gar nicht schaffen
wer für die größte volkswirtschaft mit
dem größten sozialstaat in europa die
ultimative willkommenskultur ausrufen
wir schaffen das verkündet und erklärt
kein mensch ist illegal der trick schuld
daran dass sich millionen menschen auf
den weg machen ihr leben gefährden und
europa im chaos versinkt wie das tut
es ist kein menschenfreund sondern ein
gefährlicher geisterfahrer
die bundeskanzlerin steht jetzt endlich
am ende ihrer kanzlerschaft das ist die
letzte gelegenheit etwas wieder gut zu
machen nach all dem was sie europa
angerichtet hat frau bundeskanzlerin
wenden sie sich an die migranten in der
türkei sagen sie denen dass sie in
deutschland nicht willkommen sind
erklären sie ihre solidarität mit
griechenland und zeigen sie endlich
taten gegenüber erdogan frau merkel sie
haben im amt gegenüber den taktischen
diktator bislang wenig würde gezeigt
aber sie können dann wenigstens in würde
die vielen dank
[Applaus]